as russia's war in ukraine enters a new
phase and in order to keep the military
and humanitarian aid to ukraine flowing
we need this bill to support ukraine in
this fight for freedom u.s president joe
biden on thursday asked the u.s congress
for 33 billion dollars to support
ukraine over the next five months the
cost of this fight
is not cheap
but caving to aggression is going to be
more costly if we allow it to happen
we either back ukrainian people as they
defend their country or
we stand by as the russians continue
their atrocities and aggression in
ukraine
biden's request for 33 billion dollars
includes more than 20 billion for
military assistance
like artillery and anti-aircraft
weaponry more than 8 billion to help the
ukrainian government continue to
function and another 3 billion to help
refugees in addition biden is also
sending to congress a plan to crack down
on russian oligarchs who launder illegal
and stolen money in the u.s through
shadowy purchases of yachts and other
assets like high-priced real estate the
proposal is aimed at streamlining the
federal government's ability to seize
the oligarchs property and allow the u.s
to use the proceeds to support ukraine
much of this real estate that's been
bought by oligarchs and the
political elite of russia has been
bought through front companies
and these front companies have been able
to register in the united states without
knowing who their owners are
and so it's finding this property that's
the enormous challenge at the moment
if approved by congress biden's plan
would create a new administrative
process for the forfeiture of property
owned by russian oligarchs and knowingly
or intentionally possessing funds gained
from corrupt dealings with the russian
government
could become
a criminal offense
while most members of congress support
president biden's proposals and more
money for ukraine there's little
indication of when the plan might be
debated by lawmakers
and just when the legislation might pass
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house